can you really reform Wall Street when
they are spending millions and millions
of dollars on campaign contributions and
when they are providing speaker fees to
individual the hedge fund billionaires
who are running ads against me right now
I'm the one they don't want that we ever
get the truth of the matter is Secretary
Clinton you do not go as far as reigning
in Wall Street as I would I have put
forward a plan that would actually put
cops back on the beat of Wall Street so
a bank robber robs a bank and all you do
is slap them on the wrist he's just
going to keep robbing banks again the
same thing is true with people in suits